I'm an alienated intellectual probably
most of you are as well I may have been
that before I ever reach psychedelics
basically I think that it almost comes
down to practicing a noisy form of
aesthetic criticism of the society if
something is stupid you should say so
and if something is tasteless or brutal
or insulting or demeaning we just have
to say so now the problem is there is so
much that it's tasteless insulting and
demeaning that you would spend your
entire time doing that well isn't that
what the cult the counter cultural menu
is I think it's a group of people who
see greater or lesser degrees are
entirely uncomfortable with the official
culture and then try to embody an
alternative culture and if the culture
of tolerance of broad-mindedness of
immediate experience it's not a work
ethic culture it's not a pile up well
kind of culture if the culture that
lives in the moment I mean and to my
mind what we can do is be more adamantly
counter cultural and creative that's why
I'm so happy to see something like rave
and house and ambient music come along
because you know rock and roll which was
previously the the sustaining
of the counterculture was totally
co-opted and and the counter the cult
the official culture turns all criticism
into a fashion statement that seems to
be how it operates so in terms of
embodiment I think what we have to do is
be creative at lunch I was saying you
know the culture the crisis that we're
in at the Planetary Society is a culture
of consciousness there ain't enough of
it
that's what happens when when women are
raped in Bosnia that's a failure of
consciousness that's what happens when
rivers are polluted with DDT it's a
failure of consciousness a failure to
correctly appreciate cause and effect
and if there is anything which increases
our consciousness I don't care if it's a
religion of food the drug the sexual
product a magazine if there is anything
which increases our consciousness we
should find out what it is and get with
it and once you've increased your
consciousness a little a lot some it's
not doing any good then unless it is
embodied and the way it's embodied I
think is by pushing the arc pedal to the
floor it's the only pebble which we have
been allowed to touch we don't get to
touch the international investment
profile pebble or the international
diplomacy pebble those are all reserved
for the masters but art has been ceded
to us and art can either be fawning and
sycophantic or it can be radical and
challenging or it can be transcendental
and inspiring and I think what we've
accepted in the arts in the last 20
years is the idea of immense
fragmentation
and personal expression that this is
exactly the wrong thing because what
that is is ego we don't care what jeff
koons think about the person he's
sleeping with and all this other stuff
this is just self-indulgent nonsense the
idea that art should save humanity is
very out of fashion in the cynical 90s
but I believe it and I believe and I
believe that the technologists who are
working at our elbows are giving us
tools more powerful than we or our
critics ever imagined could exist and if
we use those tools for the explicit
purpose of creating a new cultural
agenda it will be done you know we're
all a little confused about this but
those folks over on the extreme right
wing the path buchanan's of this world
they know exactly what's going on and
they call it cultural war and well
they're moving up their tanks and
digging foxholes what are we doing you
know wandering around asking what's
happening cultural war is very real and
the they the the people who are you know
if I realized sometime in the last 48
hours that when fascism comes to America
it will be called traditionalism that
seems to be how it's going to present
itself so I think art is our great our
great ace in this game right now the
most yeah
well one more thing I was going to say
right now the most exciting cultural
frontier to my mind on this planet is
the answering map than the World Wide
Web and that is a beast which escaped
from the control of the Dominator
institution it was built to wage
thermonuclear war and to be
indestructible
well when thermonuclear war ceases to be
a hot option the indestructibility of it
remained and now it can't be turned off
it can't be controlled it can't be
regulated and look who's on there I mean
guys with long hair and girls with short
hair and this Drive the Masters crazy so
I look at the Internet as a vast canvas
and to which we are each invited to make
our own contribution and if if we feed
3d to the Orthodox culture then we
should make cyberspace on our own one of
the things that I didn't stress enough
this morning was the visual acuity and
empowered by psilocybin leads to hunting
success but the higher doses of
psilocybin propel you past observation
of animal habits and environment and
into the imagination and I think you
know the cultural compass of this
species points toward the imagination
that's where we're going to live
in the future that's what we were born
for that's where we are at our best in
3d well as James Joyce says in
Finnegan's Wake here in my pain we flop
on the seaside my cane being the
red-light district of Dublin but I'm am
prospector you sprout all you're worse
than you woof your wings
well Upton a.m. is spelled these days
HTTP colon double backslash www yak yak
yak right in other words the imagination
has even turned into a piece of real
estate and the the faster we can occupy
it and give it the the caring bound
realist psychedelic communal tome of our
community the closer we are then to
having a foothold or a grasp of a real
solution
you